there's this old tradition in superhero
it's been going on for years where
men are in bad ass poses and women
always have their butt
facing you know they're always like
turning over their shoulder in the hero
pose
we've seen the end of that now do we
think should should it shift over for a
time god i hope
adam did so what's that
i'd imagine we'd probably see the end of
that do you think you've seen the end of
that i don't know i don't even remember
seeing that is that is that
that's a standard thing where the woman
is like i mean no one wants to see this
but
yeah all right good job i have to see it
from that angle yeah
here you go the woman's sort of like
this and she's looking over
and then i don't even have it's just a
straight rock right here
then the guys are all like this frontal
but it's a standard pose that's been
in most uh you know action movies for a
long time wow and i i think we can maybe
say we've seen the end of that now yeah
yeah i'm a fan of the little over the
shoulder though so yeah yeah
i'm happy to spoil it we're gonna yeah
we're gonna switch it around so you'd be
happy to do that no
let's see it will you get it right there
please yeah
okay
i like how the hammer is rested it
rested on one button
butt cheek lovely that's absolutely
incredible yeah that was fantastic